SEAN MADAY: All right.
Good afternoon, everybody.
Thanks for taking the
time to join us.
My name is Sean Maday.
I'm a product manager on the
Maps for Business team.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR:
And I'm Avnish.
I'm a technical solutions
engineer in
the Enterprise team.
SEAN MADAY: Our goal today is
to talk to you a little bit
about a project that's near and
our heart, and that is the
ability to take the consumer
experience of Google Earth and
Google Maps, and take it
completely offline, behind the
firewall, or into kind
of bandwidth
disenfranchised areas.
We're going to throw a bunch of
nomenclature at you today.
And we're going to try to
paint a picture for you.
But it would be helpful for us
if we could just kind of do a
quick poll of the audience.
And I'm going to ask
a few questions.
How many of you have ever heard
of or used Google Earth
Enterprise?
Great.
OK.
For those joining us via video,
there's thousands of
people in attendance, and they
all raised their hand.
How about Portable?
How many of you have
ever used Portable?
The product we call Portable?
OK.
Great.
How about Google Maps Engine?
How many of you have
ever been hands on
with Google Maps Engine?
Great.
OK.
That's very helpful.
Thank you.
As we go forward, for those of
you who weren't familiar with
any of those three products,
we'll make sure that we make
that clear to you.
Before we begin, I want to touch
on some current events.
You woke up this morning to
headlines that a series of
really severe tornadoes had
struck just southwest of the
Dallas-Fort Worth area.
A lot of times, we see this
type of headline.
But these headlines get kind
of lost in the news cycle.
But instrumental to the relief
and response effort in the
aftermath of a critical
incident, or a natural
disaster like this,
is usually a map.
And the context that that map
could provide to us as kind of
fellow Americans, or fellow
citizens of Earth, but also to
first responders and emergency
managers who are going to be
trying to restore and provide
relief for those affected.
So I just want to provide some
context with the map.
I'll show you here.
These are the four counties that
were primarily affected.
The green dots, or the green
placemarks you see here, were
kind of initial observations
that were recorded this
morning by several local
news affiliates.
And then the blue placemarks
you see here are actually
confirmed touchdowns that the
National Weather Service just
put out a few hours ago.
As we zoom in and we pan around
these affected areas,
the map is a really interesting
way for us to kind
of get some appreciation for
what this human terrain and
this natural landscape
looks like.
For those emergency managers
who are going to be
responsible for understanding
the scope and extent of this
devastation, and for those first
responders who are going
to be going door to door,
assessing damage and looking
for those who are injured or
afflicted, these sorts of maps
can be absolutely critical to
understanding and getting the
lay of the land.
So what we want to do today is
we want to illustrate to you
that these maps are obviously
very impactful and very useful
in an online setting, but they
can become even more useful.
They can become a
force multiplier
in an offline scenario.
Actually, the demo I'm
showing you here
is completely offline.
This is all running on my local
machine from the local
host URL you see at the
top of the screen.
All of these map tiles were cut
from Google Maps Engine.
These are Google Map tiles
down to level 17.
You get some very granular,
street level understanding.
But all of this is
coming offline.
So in the aftermath of these
critical incidents, when
there's limited or no
connectivity to the outside
world, that's really where this
story of offline begins.
As we take you through today,
that's going to kind of set
the expectation for what you
should see, and what we're
going to show you, and how you
can extend on these platforms.
You've heard some big numbers
over the last few days from
folks like Brian McClendon
and Manu Markes.
And they've talked to you about
the absolute ubiquity of
the Google Maps and Google
Earth platforms.
A billion users a week, a
million websites out there on
the open internet have
implemented the Maps API.
Google Maps has become the
platform whereby people go to
make fast, informed decisions
about geography.
Right?
So asset tracking, looking for
information about where to
live, where to shop,
what to buy.
Google Earth becomes the
substrate, or the backdrop, by
which these sorts of
engagements occur.
The focus of our team, and then
the focus of the product
we're going to show you today,
is really on how to extend
this functionality into
situations and scenarios where
that connectivity to the outside
world is unavailable
or is significantly degraded.
We talked to the emergency
management, or emergency
response type scenario, but
there are many other scenarios
that play a role here.
Paramount among them, things
like research and outreach.
Things that take researchers
and scientists to far off
areas of the globe where they
just don't have connectivity
to the rest of the world.
Then there's certainly lots of
interesting defense and public
safety applications for this
sort of technology.
So with that, let's dive
and talk a little
bit more about Portable.
Google Maps Engine Portable, or
Portable, as we call it, is
the product that takes the
familiarity of Google Earth
and Google Maps offline behind
the firewall, deploys it on
your own network, on your
own local device.
We have builds of Portable for
Mac, Windows, and laptop.
And to be totally
transparent--
I want to be very clear-- this
is an enterprise track.
These are generally
paid products.
Although we have a very
robust outreach, and
develop for good effort.
If you work with an NGO, or
you work in the nonprofit
space, we would love to get you
a grant for this sort of
functionality so that you can
empower your constituents with
this technology.
We're also excited to foreshadow
some releases in
the months ahead, where we will
take this capability to
Android tablets and
smartphones.
Portable, as it exists today,
is a laptop application,
desktop application,
which builds for
Mac, Linux, and Windows.
It scales from one to 10 users,
so you could either run
the scenario locally on your
individual machine, or sit in
a small tactical operations,
or team type environment,
where you could share
that experience
across up to 10 devices.
And at its essence, behind
Portable is really just a
lightweight, Tornado
web server.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with Tornado, it's an
open sourced, kind of massively
scalable web serving
application.
Very powerful, and it provides
the foundation by which we
deliver the Portable
functionality.
As we step deeper into this
Portable ecosystem, Portable
is the client software that will
serve up a Maps on Earth
experience.
But what it serves is a portable
cache, or as we may
refer to it, a cut.
A map or a globe that has been
packaged and prepared for
offline use.
There's a couple ways
right now to build
one of these cuts.
The first is with Google
Earth Enterprise.
For those of you who've used
Google Earth Enterprise, or
have access to Google Earth
Enterprise, you have the
ability to extract a portion,
or even the entirety of your
Google Earth Enterprise Maps on
Earth experience into this
file format so that
you can use it in
these offline settings.
We're also really excited to
bring online in the next
couple months the capability to
cut this rich map data out
of the Google Maps
Engine enclave.
All of you, I'm sure, have
heard, but we would love to
get to Google Maps Engine
into your hands.
If you come visit us at the
Sandbox, come visit us at the
booth, we'll give you
information so that you can
start a free trial of the Google
Maps Engine platform.
It's a very exciting way to take
lots of imagery, terrain,
and vector data, process it in
the cloud, and then very soon,
you'll be able to pull out
these maps and earth
experiences for completely
offline use.
The output of either of these
two processes is a .GLC file.
Right?
This is your portable cut.
With that cut, you could do
some interesting things.
But let's first dive into
what that cut is.
That cut, as we call it,
is really just a
single binary file.
It can be very large.
It can be very small.
It's really restricted only by
the file size limitations of
your file system.
It carries the .GLC extension.
In the past, if you have used
Google Earth Enterprise, you
may have seen a .GLM
or .GLB file.
.GLC is the new, kind of
standard wrapper that will
encompass all of these Portable
caches going forward.
We also have the ability to
include into this binary file
a custom point of interest
search, so that it your users,
or your constituents, your
stakeholders, need to search
against this rich corpus of
data you're giving them
offline, we want to give you
the ability to define the
points that they can
search against.
So now that we have this cut
that we've taken from Google
Earth Enterprise or Google Maps
Engine, we can drop it
seamlessly into the
Portable server.
And once it's on the Portable
server, we have some really
interesting ways to interact and
extend this functionality.
Avnish is going to dig into
this a little deeper.
But at a high level, you can
think of this as the Earth API
and the Maps API you're
familiar with from the
consumer internet, packaged
and deployed in a slightly
modified data on your
local device.
You can also interact with these
caches via the Google
Earth Enterprise client, that
is to say our version of
Google Earth Pro that isn't
hardwired to Google servers.
We'll show you some examples
of that when we
jump into the demos.
Then of course, we have some
interesting and evolving ways
for you to interact with this
Portable Map or Earth
experience using Android
devices.
So with that, let's talk through
how we create one of
these Portable maps or globes.
The basic building block of
cutting a Portable is really
to define your area
of interest.
And that's done with
the KML polygon.
It can be as simple
or as complex a
polygon as you see fit.
It can be a single polygon, or
it could be a multi-polygon,
depending on your use cases.
It is specified simply
with KML.
Once you have specified your
KML, you'll make some
decisions about how deep
into the cuts.
And when I say deep, I'm talking
about how many zoom
levels deep into the cut you
will want to extract that
data, and then how far outside
the cut you're going to want
to extract that data.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with zoom levels,
it's the way that we take a lot
of map data and make it
discoverable at different zoom
levels with varying degrees of
resolution and numbers of tiles,
based on how far in or
out you have zoomed
and panned.
Today, for those of you using
Google Earth Enterprise or who
have access to a Google Earth
Enterprise system, you have a
couple different ways to kick
off one of these cuts.
The first is with a simple
HTML5 interface.
That is something I'll
show you right now.
This is the cutting interface
that will be released with
Google Earth Enterprise 4.5 in
just another couple weeks.
Here, I'm looking at a
two dimensional map.
This map has fairly low
resolution satellite imagery
for the entire world.
Four kilometer satellite
imagery.
So fairly low resolution.
But as I zoom and pan, you'll
notice the map is truly a
Google map.
This looks, and feels, and
interacts like a Google map.
From the cutter here, I have the
ability to define an area
of interest.
So let's say I want to take kind
of the Western seaboard
of the United States, just shy
of the Washington border.
And once I've defined my polygon
here, I can also kind
of redefine the points
of interest.
From there, I'll have the
ability to state a name.
So maybe I want to call this
my West Coast Globe.
I can throw in a description.
As you can imagine, over time,
you can generate a lot of
these cuts on your
local machine.
You can generate a lot
of these cuts that go
out into the field.
So you're going to want to be as
descriptive as possible to
make sure that you capture what
is inside of this cut.
Certainly here, we'll just
make an example.
But you can be as verbose
as you would like.
Using these pull-down menus,
we'll decide again how deep we
want to cut inside the polygon,
and how deep we want
to cut outside the polygon.
So here, I'm simply going
to make some arbitrary
selections.
We'll say zoom level four
for the entire world.
That's a very low resolution.
The entire world represented on
a very few number of tiles.
And we'll cut to level 18
inside the polygon.
That is a large number of tiles,
down to generally about
one meter resolution, if we
were talking in imagery.
And then we can kick
off that cut.
It's an asynchronous process.
It kind of happens here
in the browser window.
Lots of dialogue coming
back to tell us how
big that cut is getting.
And this was a fairly small
cut, because I had low
resolution imagery.
So it's indicated that
the cut is complete.
In addition to that user
interface, The HTML5 user
interface that we package with
Google Earth Enterprise, we
also have command line utilities
that would allow you
to script this workflow.
We'll dig a little deeper into
that in a couple slides.
But some really exciting ways
there to kick off cuts
programmatically.
And the neat thing here--
and this is kind of a departure
from the capability
we've been able to offer with
the online version of Google
Earth or Google Earth
Enterprise--
we have the ability with
Portable to let you offer your
users and your viewers up to
five layers of imagery.
So I'd like to show
you that now.
Here I'm logged into the Google
Earth Enterprise client.
I'm going to zip back to
Portable, and I'm going to
change the Portable map that
I'm currently serving.
So this is the Portable
interface as it exists.
As I mentioned to you, HTML5
interface, it looks about the
same on Mac, Windows,
or Linux.
Here, I'm going to say that
I want to serve up my
Las Vegas 3D globe.
Now that that's serving, I can
jump back to the Earth
Enterprise client.
And in addition to being logged
into Google's globe,
which isn't necessary, but just
happens to be what I have
here, I'm going to log in to
my local host address.
You'll notice in the lower left
hand corner, I've now
added a second database
that I can explore.
And as we zoom in, I can
actually turn off all the
imagery, terrain, and vector
data associated
with Google's globe.
So we just see this small patch
of alpha massed imagery
that we cut over the
Las Vegas strip.
Now you'll notice in the lower
left hand corner, we have five
different imagery layers
that represent
this particular scene.
So as a user now, I can come
back and forth, and look at
these individual dates.
I can see what this scene
looked like in 2010.
I can see what it looked
like in 2003.
We've had this ability to
support historic imagery in
Google Earth for a long time.
But Portable gives you the
flexibility to actually use
the transparency slider to step
back and forth between
these individual scenes.
So we can really look at how
this landscape has changed
between any of the five imagery
layers that are
denoted in lower left
hand corner of our
Google Earth display.
Very cool way to kind
of understand
that change over time.
We're really excited, and we
have a really strong team of
engineers working hard on the
ability to allow cutting of
portables from Google
Maps Engine.
So this is coming soon, a little
bit later in 2013.
But in the Google Maps Engine
interface, we'll have a
browser-based capability for
you to define the polygon,
your point of interest, choose
the layers you want to cut,
and kick off an asynchronous
cut.
Take large amounts of map data,
combine them into a
single binary file that you can
pull from the cloud, and
serve locally on
your machines.
This is working today.
Actually, some of the demos I'm
showing you here, like the
Texas demo, was actually cut
from Google Maps Engine.
Again, we're just kind of
working on making this
capability more robust.
We're really excited to get
it in the hands of trusted
testers in the next
couple months.
In addition to what we're
offering inside of the HTML5
interface, we also are going to
allow programmatic access.
Again, you could kick off these
cuts programmatically.
Our vision going forward is
really to offer some composite
solutions that allow you to
leverage both the cloud,
you're on-premise geospatial
investments, and new emerging
form factors for devices to
create familiar Google Earth
and Google Maps experiences that
your users can interact
with completely offline.
Whether those tiles come from
Google Earth Enterprise,
Google Maps Engine, maybe even
cutting Google basemap tiles,
as we mature that capability,
you should be able to
consolidate these individual
cuts, and create the custom
map environment that your
users need, but with the
familiarity that Google Earth
and Google Maps has instilled
in these consumers.
Right in line with this
is this ability to cut
programmatically.
What I really like about this
is we hearken back to that
disaster response scenario.
This gives us some really
exciting ways to proactively
respond to natural disasters
and critical incidents.
What do I mean by that.?
Well, the National Weather
Service puts out the map you
see in the upper left
hand corner.
24 hours a day, 365 days a year,
they're monitoring all
3,141 different counties
in the United States.
And they're monitoring the
weather patterns that are
affecting the people inside
of those counties.
They're putting out this
large, common, alerting
protocol, XML, or CAP, as
they kind of call it.
At every given moment, this
thing is updated.
It shows which counties are
under a flood advisory, which
counties are under a severe
winter weather advisory, which
counties are under a
tornado warning.
With this sort of rich data, and
the programmatic access to
cutting that is currently
available today in Google
Earth Enterprise and quickly
becoming available in Google
Maps Engine, we can start
to script some
really interesting solutions.
So for instance, the Texas demo
I showed you earlier,
simply scrape through this XML,
look for counties that
had progressed from a tornado
watch to a tornado warning.
It then combined the geographic
bounds for those
counties into a single polygon,
passed that polygon
into the Google Maps Engine
cutter, and allowed us to kick
off that cut programmatically
the minute those
warnings were issued.
So to follow that chain of kind
of thinking, that would
allow your organization, or
first responders anywhere, to
have access to this rich,
offline map data by the time
that they get the alert that
a storm is impending.
To do this, we'll just throw up
a couple code samples that
would let you kind
of dig into this.
But it's as simple as just using
some Python to reach
out, grab that XML from the
National Weather Service, read
it into your local system, parse
through it, and then as
you parse through it, look
for alerts that pass your
particular threshold.
Those warnings, those alerts,
tornadoes, floods, whatever
may fit your absolute
use case.
Another interesting
implementation of this is
something that our colleague,
Sean Wohltman, has put a lot
of passion behind for the last
few years, and that is making
this data available offline in
response to large hurricanes.
And so the National Weather
Service, in conjunction with
the National Oceanographic and
Atmospheric Administration,
puts out these cones of
uncertainty whenever a major
hurricane is bound for
the United States.
We can, again, follow the same
workflow to reach out, grab
that data, do something with
that polygon to convert it to
KML, so that we can use it
inside the Google Maps Engine
or Google Earth Enterprise
cutting infrastructure.
Here, this was as simple as
just a wget to grab it.
We needed to unzip the zip
file that the National
Oceanographic and Atmospheric
Administration and the
National Weather Service had put
out, and then just use an
open source vector processing
tool, like OGR, to convert it
from a shape file into a KML.
Once we have that KML,
we can feed it
into Google Maps Engine.
We can feed it into Google
Earth Enterprise.
And we can do that
programmatically to cut this
data, and make it available.
So now that we've set the
foundation for what Portable
is, and what it can do for you,
Avnish is going to talk
about how motivated and creative
developers like
yourself can extend this
functionality to do
interesting things in your
applications completely offline.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR:
Thanks, Sean.
So Sean has nicely described the
workflow for cutting, and
creating, and serving your
portable globes.
So now, let's say you've done
all that, and now you have
this GLB, GLC file that's
sitting on your hard disk.
It could be tens of megabytes,
or several terabytes in size,
depending on your cut
that you made.
Now you're interested in serving
this out, and building
your applications
on top of it.
Now sure, you could launch the
Enterprise Client or the
Mobile Client that come out of
the box with these products,
and do your globe that way.
But where's the fun
in that, right?
You want to be able to build
your own custom applications
that are targeted for your
specific use case and
environment.
So how do you do that?
Well, the key is the Google
APIs that you
all know and love.
Namely the Google Maps API,
the Google Earth, the
JavaScript API.
Now conveniently, we offer
these with the product.
They come bundled with Google
Earth Enterprise server, as
well as the Portable server.
They are typically kept in--
they align in terms of the
version with the latest frozen
release that's out
on google.com.
Fundamentally, the version of
the API that comes with the
Portable server is the same as
what you find on google.com
with respect to the events, such
as the mouse over, click,
double click.
You have the same type
of controls.
Zoom, pan, scale, plus all
the custom controls.
You have overlays, such
as symbols, markers,
polylines, et cetera.
But there are some subtle
differences in the API that we
provide with the Portable server
compared to the one
that you load on google.com.
Some of those differences
include the way you actually
call and invoke those APIs.
Because obviously, you're
not going to be
getting them from Google.
You're going to be getting them
from the Portable server.
So they need to be loaded in
your web page from there.
And there's certain classes that
are offered to make it
easier to interact with the
2D and the 3D map tiles.
And I'm going to talk about
that in a moment.
And as you might also guess,
there's no support for certain
types of services, like the
Direction service, Panaramio,
Street View, et cetera, services
that require access
to Google's infrastructure.
So before we get into the sort
of nitty gritty, let me review
the workflow for hosting
a 2D map on Portable.
Typically, you're going to build
your 2D map either in
Google Earth Enterprise
Fusion, or, as Sean
demonstrated, in Google
Maps Engine.
You're going to choose the
layers of interest, your
imagery, your vector layers,
possibly some terrain.
At that point, you're going
to publish that 2D map.
In the case of GME, that's just
a matter of one click,
and making it available to
the folks that you share.
And in the case of Fusion, you
would typically publish it to
an Earth Enterprise server.
At that point, you're going
to cut a piece of that map
corresponding to the region of
interest, exactly the way Sean
demonstrated.
The output of that is going
to be that GLC file.
At that point, you're going to
start serving that GLC file to
the Portable server, and then
you can start building your
custom HTML applications that
load the JavaScript API.
What I'd like to do now, I have
here a little USB memory
stick that contains a GLC file
from a globe that I published
from Google Earth Enterprise.
It's a relatively small one.
A few hundred megabytes from a
sample, natural view globe
that I had created.
It's just got the base imagery
layer, and maybe one or two
vector layers.
According to the blue box, I had
built that globe of mine
in Fusion, and then I published
it to my Earth
Enterprise Server, the red box,
and then I cut it using
the Portable cutter UI.
So what I'm going to do
now is insert this
USB disk on my laptop.
And before doing that,
I'm going to go
completely off the grid.
Turn off Wi-Fi here.
It was like one of those corny
moments in a movie where they
use the title of the movie
in the actual dialogue.
I said off the grid.
I like it.
So I fire up my natural view,
US Portable globe, which
automatically by double clicking
it, kicks off the
Portable server that
I have running here
on my Windows laptop.
I click on View the
Map in a Browser.
It shows me a preview,
essentially,
of the globe I created.
Now, if you look at the URL
here, at this point, this map,
this globe is being served
from my Windows
machine on Port 9335.
So at this point, I can
start interacting
with this globe directly.
So I have a little Hello World
example that I'm going to go
over, that I'm going
to load here.
And let's take a look at the
source code for this.
These three lines here is where
I actually load the
Google Maps API that's on
my Portable server.
After the bootstrap loader,
the fusion_maps_v3 and the
other JavaScript helper file
essentially load the entire
Google Maps API into
this application.
So that's one of the
differences.
Then down here, you'll note
the use the class called
GFusionMap, which is--
you can think of it as
an extension of the
google.maps.mapclass.
And it's what you need to
instantiate in order to create
your 2D map in your HTML
container, which is typically
a development.
This class accepts the same
options as google.maps.map,
and can be used in
the same way.
And that's it.
That's all you need to do to
load 2D map in this simple
Hello World application.
Let's look at, maybe,
a few more examples.
I have one that loads some
symbols and polylines.
Now, here what I'm displaying is
certain markers that can be
used to decorate not
just points, but
polylines, as well.
It's making use of the
visualization features of the
Google Maps API.
But you'll note this math is
completely interactive.
In other words, I interact with
this map in the same way
that I would any Google map.
This was the area that I cut
in the San Francisco.
The area outside
of it is, well,
outside of my cut region.
But I can zoom in to the highest
resolution that was in
my original basemap.
And I can zoom, pan, scale,
all that good stuff.
Again, this is running
completely offline.
Let's have a look at
another example.
Perhaps a heat map.
This is showing a time-based
based animation of the
expansion of Walmart stores
since the 1960s until now.
You can, again, use the
visualization capabilities in
the Google Maps API, varying
the intensity and the color
spectrum of the heat map.
And as before, I can interact
with this just as with any
other Google map.
I believe I have one other
example here to show
SEAN MADAY: These are the same
visualization demonstrations
and code examples you'll
find online using
public the Maps API.
The power here, of course, is
that it's all running off of
Avnish's local machine via
that local host URL.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Right.
Again, this is another
time-based based animation
showing the expansion of
these Walmart stores.
SEAN MADAY: Our goal with these
demonstrations and code
samples is really to highlight
to you the
flexibility of this platform.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: And this is
against my base map that I had
cut, and it's all being
served out of this USB
drive that I have here.
Let's go back.
I guess I got to get back
online to resume the
presentation.
SEAN MADAY: We can use mine.
Here you go.
I got mine on.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: OK, thanks.
SEAN MADAY: Yep.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: So in that
Hello World example that I
just showed you, I've
highlighted the lines here
that would be needed to load
the JavaScript API off the
Portable server instead
of from google.com.
And again, you want to pay close
attention to the use of
this GFusionMap, which is what
you would need to instantiate.
SEAN MADAY: All these
slides will be made
available after the talk.
So again, these code samples
aren't meant to be eye charts.
We want to leave these with you
as a resource that you can
reference later.
AVNISH BHATNAGAR: Right.
And very analogous to the 2D
maps, we offer the 3D map API,
which is a Google Earth API.
It also is supported through
the use of the Google Earth
plug-in, which runs on
Windows and Mac.
And that API includes all the
capabilities that you're
probably familiar with from
placemarks, to balloons, and
historic imagery, et cetera.
In addition, it offers the
capability to connect to
multiple globes.
So this is a snippet of a Hello
World example for 3D.
Again, you're going to load the
JavaScript API from the
Portable server locally.
That's what the script
typeline is.
In the
google.earth.createinstance
call, there's a fourth
parameter, which is the URL of
the database that you're
connecting to.
An alternative database, other
than Google's default one.
And in this case, I'm pointing
back to my local machine
because my portable server
is running on Port 9335.
Other than that; you
use the Earth API
exactly the same way.
So its sensibility doesn't
just end with the Maps
and the Earth API.
It can be leveraged through
Python, as well.
And Sean is going to speak
about them now.
SEAN MADAY: As I mentioned to
you, the basis of laptop
Portable is really the open
source Tornado web server.
Inherent in that, and packaged
in that, is the most current
release of Python.
So we're providing you APIs and
tools that allow you to
leverage that Python inside of
your offline applications to
interact with the Google Earth
or Google Maps offline
environments.
So you can imagine this as a
framework for adding extension
services on top of the Google
Earth and Google Maps portable
experiences that you get as
a baseline with Portable.
You can execute Python
scripts.
You can install standard
Python libraries.
You can engage in some
interesting interaction
between the Maps environment and
the type of backend system
that would normally be reserved
for a web server.
Right?
So as you can see in the chart
here, you could grab
view-based parameters from
either Google Earth or Google
Maps, grab those click-based
events from the Google Maps
environment, pass those to
this Python engine, do
something interesting with
them, and return those
responses as either JSON or KML,
depending on if you're
using Google Earth
or Google Maps.
So one example of that-- and
just two code snippets.
Again, don't expect you to read
these, but want to make
sure that we provide them in the
slide so you can reference
them after the talk.
First is just creating a network
link, and specifying
which parameters from that
network link should be passed
back from the Google Earth
environment back
to the Python server.
Then a couple lines of Python
here to grab those parameters
from the URL, do something with
them, and then return
that experience as KML.
Let me show you an example
of that here.
I'm back in Google Earth.
I'll turn back on some of our
Google's offline imagery.
Now, as I zoom and pan here,
you'll notice I have this
network link on the left side.
This is pointing back to a local
service running on my
local host address here.
So local host 9235, and
the extension service.
All the service is really doing
is taking the center
point for the screen, or just
about the center point for a
screen, based on terrain, and
returning it to me as a KML.
This interaction is the type of
interaction you'd expect to
see with a KML network link in
a backend web server on the
internet, or on your
local network.
Here, all of this KML is being
generated on the fly by that
Python engine running
with Portable.
So a very simple Hello
World-type demonstration.
Our goal today was really just
to show you this platform and
this product, to let you know
that our team is working very
intently on taking the
capabilities of Google Earth
and Google Maps from the
online cloud-based
environments down to those
tactical scenarios where
internet connectivity is
degraded or unavailable.
We're really looking to your
creativity, and your technical
expertise, to take this
platform, build it out in
interesting ways, integrate it
with your offline applications
for your constituents and
stakeholders, and take this
ecosystem forward.
With that, we're just about
to wrap up here.
I would like to just say that
I'm very fortunate that I get
to be the product
manager for this
awesome suite of products.
I get to come out and
present to you.
But I'd be remiss if I passed on
this opportunity to really
thank the awesome team of
engineers we have back in
Mountain View, and abroad, who
are doing really impressive
things at Google scale to take
the world's geospatial data,
make it consumable online and
offline for your use.
With that, we have about
four and 1/2 minutes.
We would love to entertain any
questions you might have Sir,
in the back of the room, you
want to come use the mic so we
can capture it for the video?
Thank you.
Sorry to make you walk
across the room.
So now can you go use
that microphone?
No.
AUDIENCE: So big use case
here is data capture.
How are we doing with capturing
data then uploading
it back to Google Maps Engine?
SEAN MADAY: Yeah.
Great question.
So we view this as the offline
product that gives you the
view-only capability.
Then what we can envision are
some interesting ways that you
could use local storage, either
through the HTML5 spec,
or possibly with that Python
engine, you could do some
local writing to the device.
Handle that field data
collection piece, and then
sync that back up via the Google
Maps Engine API, which
was just announced and released
last week, and then
kind of reiterated yesterday.
A full vector API for Google
Maps Engine that allows you to
write points, lines,
and polygons.
So the pieces are there.
I think that's really where
the developers come in.
We like to think of ourselves
as a platform company.
We like to provide the
platforms and the
capabilities, and then we rely
on you all and your expertise
to make this relevant in your
individual vertical markets.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick
extension.
So there's no thoughts about
sort of editing on--
well, I guess wouldn't be on the
fly-- but stopping merge
issues, and that
kind of stuff?
SEAN MADAY: So the Google Maps
Engine API handles some of
that version control.
Then some of that is on their
roadmap for how they're going
to handle and deconflict.
Again, what's really exciting
at Google is we tackle these
massive scale problems.
The underlying infrastructure
for the Google Maps Engine API
is a really impressive piece of
technology called Spanner.
There's a great white
paper on the open
internet about Spanner.
Check it out.
It really handles all of these
conflicting edits in a very
elegant way, and does really
interesting things at a kind
of a global database scale.
So definitely check that out.
And the integration of the
Google Maps Engine API with
the offline capabilities of
Portable is exactly the type
of thing we're intent on helping
develop, and helping
move forward in this
ecosystem.
AUDIENCE: Thanks very much.
SEAN MADAY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the new JavaScript API
that's probably coming
out for Google Maps.
The preview functionality that
we saw, and it kind of brings
a three dimensional aspects
to a lot of the Maps API.
For Portable, will it also get
that same functionality at the
same time as the preview gets
rolled out to become
mainstream?
SEAN MADAY: Interesting
question.
Interesting way to phrase
the question.
As you can imagine,
we are kind of an
API-driven company, right?
So don't have any announcements
to make, but
we're very focused on how we can
allow you all, and empower
you all, to build on
these platforms.
What you saw the other day with
the new Google Maps is
really kind of a cutting edge,
immersive experience that
still needs some assurance.
Still needs to grow
a little bit.
As that does, as there's more
functionality and capability
added there, we're very focused
on and taking the best
and brightest of that technology
and making it
available offline.
But today, Google Maps Engine
Portable, and what we're doing
with offline, is really focused
on that consumer Maps
and Earth experience that users
have been accustomed to
for the last two years.
Those are the platforms that,
today, consumers are using to
make fast, informed decisions
about geography.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SEAN MADAY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: OK,.
I would like to know with the
Google Maps Portable, so we
can craft a Google Maps online
to an offline basis, and also
allow for some of the Maps API
that do not need to have
internet access.
Am I correct?
SEAN MADAY: It's a great point,
and a great point of
clarification I'm glad
you brought up.
In the public version of Google
Earth, for instance,
you're seeing lots of different
imagery that Google
has acquired from a variety of
different imagery providers.
And we commingle and mix a lot
of those pixels to provide a
really cohesive visualization
experience.
We don't expect to release the
ability to cut from Google's
public imagery repository.
What we are intensely focused
on is how you can cut your
imagery out of Google Maps
Engine, and then how, also, we
can leverage the power of the
data we use to build Google
Maps tiles, the two dimensional
tiles, and allow
you to take those offline for
use behind the firewall.
We, or on your local device.
So that capability for the
Google Map tiles offline is
rapidly coming online.
We're really looking for the
right trusted testers in the
ecosystem who could help us
prove that capability and that
functionality.
But to just be very clear,
cutting Google's imagery is
not something that's currently
on our roadmap.
Thank you.
With that, we're out of time.
I would like to thank you
all for your time.
And Avnish and I will be around
afterward, if you'd
like to engage in any
further discussion.
Thanks.
Have a great day.